there's a lot of prevention uh
you know getting in you know segwaying
into like medicine and dentistry
uh there's not a lot of money in
prevention in dental and dentistry
now as the consumer you should take that
as i should be preventative
because that's how i'm going to spend
less money dennis we don't get a lot of
money
we don't make our money we don't buy our
boats and our big houses from
your cleaning fees that's not what we're
that's not what we're making
we're making money off your neglect
we're making money off when
you decide you're not going to do that
and you know the biggest
you know you know the biggest uh
difference maker is don't be the guy or
gal
who comes to the dentist and says it's
been eight years since i've seen a
dentist
all right everybody we're doing
something totally different this week
i'm
very excited and psyched to be doing
this joining me today is dr brady smith
he is the founder of the halo dental
network
and host of the drilled podcast we're
going to talk about teeth and dental
hygiene and all that good stuff for just
a little bit
and then we're going to share how one of
you watching this
right this very second will win a free
smile makeover
from dr smith a totally free smile
makeover from dr smith and he'll even
fly out to portland to do it
i am not getting anything for this dr
smith reached out to me we thought it
was a great
idea i'm thrilled to be a part so dr
brady smith welcome to the reuben report
hey thanks for having me i thought
you're going to keep the portland part
secret that's a hard sell to get someone
to fly out of portland
you know when i was writing when i was
writing the intro just then i thought
maybe i should write pacific
northwest but you do some stuff in
washington as well right
yeah my practice is actually in
vancouver washington so we're actually
enough removed a way that that you
should be able to avoid any
frozen water bottles being thrown at you
getting your teeth done with me
actually come to think of it maybe we
should just open this up to the antifa
people because a lot of them the dental
hygiene is not looking so great
listen everyone everyone's got teeth
you're absolutely right man
we got to take care of everybody right
everyone's got teeth
well pretty much everyone's got teeth
i'm sure i'm sure you've seen some cases
that
that get pretty close all right so let's
just start at the beginning
and then at the end of the conversation
we're going to lay out how people
uh can actually be the one that we're
going to select to get the full smile
makeover
um just tell me a little bit about why
you got into dentistry your passion
because your story is actually
pretty great you you love what you're
doing you love helping people and doing
this this won't be the first time you've
done a free smile makeover
yeah but it didn't start that way for me
at all in fact uh you know the reason i
got into dentistry
ultimately was i had a mentor growing up
i guess you'd call him and uh you know
he just had a great lifestyle he was
able to he was a boy scout leader i was
in boy scouts and he was a great boy
scout leader and i liked him a lot
and the reason he was always so
available because he only worked three
days a week
because he was a dentist so uh
i had one experience where he pulled a
fish hook out of my head because i
didn't know how to fish very well i got
one stuck in the back of my head one
time
so he helped me out with that but
honestly
the reason i got into it was it's a good
lifestyle
what happened to me after eight years of
education
and three hundred thousand dollars of
debt
about three or four years into my career
i hated my job
i didn't like what i was doing and
that's a really difficult career to try
to 180 from
you know it's just so much intense
investment that you can't really turn
away from that
so that was the position i found myself
in and then i did a couple things that
kind of took personal inventory of my
life
and i kind of repurposed what i was
doing and one thing that i knew was
lacking in my life was personal uh you
know charitable
service to other people i had grown up
with that being instilled in me as an
important value and it's just something
that i had just
stopped doing or not been really
putting too much attention to that so
when i started putting
a little bit more attention to that
doing charitable service for other
people
it's like totally changed the way that i
feel about what i
was doing um it's like this like i hate
mowing lawns
i hate mowing lawns i grew up mowing
lawns my dad made me mow the lawn i
hated it
but you know there's an old lady who's a
widow in my church
and she needs her lawn mowed and in that
one circumstance
i don't mind doing it in fact i love
doing it
because it's doing it for someone who
can't do it for themselves
and so when i changed the way i thought
about the dentistry that i was doing
when
i changed the way i looked at it i was
doing the same thing over and over again
but now i enjoy it because of the
repurposing
of how i'm doing it and the why the why
am i doing it and now i love going to
work now i love doing dentistry and now
it changed my whole perspective on
things yeah and it really does
change people's lives right when when
you really fix a smile i don't think
i've ever said this publicly before but
when i was a kid i was about
seven eight years old and a babysitter
whacked me over the head with a pillow
and my face
hit the uh the formica that was
surrounding bed basically destroyed my
two front adult teeth
which were you know that one was like
completely destroyed one was about
60 percent destroyed i had bonding and
all kinds of stuff over the years
now these are these are crowns here
that's some porcelain right there
uh but getting them fixed getting them
fixed
you feel better about yourself when your
teeth look good you feel good it's just
it's just true yeah no it affects your
confidence either negatively or
positively depending on what your teeth
look like
but absolutely you know one of the first
cases i ever did
uh this is i'm going to confess a little
bit here i spend a little bit too much
time in the wendy's drive through
and there was this woman that i always
saw i went there like three or four
times a week
i loved wendy's so but there was always
the same girl
giving my food and she had very visibly
destroyed
teeth and i couldn't help you know the
amount of times that i saw her the
amount of interaction i had with her i
couldn't help but
you know overwhelmingly think about
all i have to do is make the offer
and i could change this person's life
like
tremendously change this person's life
and so she was one of the first people i
ever ever ever reached out
to before there was a non-profit
organization before i had a podcast
it was just hey here's my card i just
want to help you if you come to my
office
you won't spend a dollar just let me
help you out
she was super friendly i mean just like
the most friendly person with
terrible teeth and we are able to make a
huge difference for her
but you're absolutely correct the
ability that
dentists have to change people's lives
is tremendous so i have a i have a
theory
that every dentist at least every
dentist that i've ever been to in my
life
is a closeted comedian every dentist
seems to want to make people laugh more
than anything else it has something to
do with
one-way communication you just jam a lot
of stuff in people's mouths
and then you can talk for a while and
they kind of have to laugh at what
you're saying i got to give a shout out
here to my
my childhood dentist stu kaminsky in
long island who was probably the
funniest guy
i know but but all of my dentists
actually over the years they all want to
make people laugh
is this a crazy theory i'm throwing at
you oh it's a slight of hand trick
dave it's uh we we uh we have to admit
that what we do is
terrible and so the only thing we can do
is try to make you laugh and forget for
just a second that
a needle is going to get poked in your
gums to numb you up for whatever
procedure we're doing
so uh yeah you know i think
i'll speak for myself i love being able
to make people laugh and people making
people feel more comfortable in the
chair
uh if you talk to my staff listen i
gotta change up my material
probably because i it's the same tired
jokes they hit well
in a first first-time audience but uh my
staff is like rolling their eyes like oh
this joke again oh man
yeah yeah all right so all right so
before we
we get into the to the giveaway
specifically i just want to do a little
bit on just like
general dental hygiene stuff let's just
give some people
let's give people some 101 stuff and
then just a little bit about the
business behind that because you've had
some interesting
uh interesting thoughts on that uh just
the dental hygiene 101. i brush three
times a day i actually do a midday brush
i work from home so i'm usually able to
do a midday brush that's pretty good
i try to floss every day what else
should people be doing
russian flossing are we good to go is
that enough now or what else are you
what are you what are you telling people
to do listen it's the first great
answers right it's the first great
answers it's it's brush
floss a mouth rinse i would add to that
make sure you're seeing a competent
professional
once every six months there's a lot of
prevention
uh you know getting in you know
segwaying into like medicine and
dentistry
uh there's not a lot of money in
prevention in dental in dentistry
now as the consumer you should take that
as i should be preventative
because that's how i'm gonna spend less
money dennis we don't get a lot of money
we don't make our money we don't buy our
boats and our big houses from
your cleaning fees that's not what we're
that's not what we're making
we're making money off your neglect
we're making money off when
you decide you're not going to do that
and you know the biggest
you know you know the biggest uh
difference maker is don't be the guy or
gal
who comes to the dentist and says it's
been eight years since i've seen a
dentist
uh you know or been five years or seven
years or 12 years
that happens all the time and those
people are the people who pay the most
but being preventative same in medicine
you know
is diet and exercise part of health care
is that
under the definition of health care i
don't think it really is considered to
be yeah well
in in reality it should be but yeah in
100 it should be so diet you know being
preventative
the problem is how does a pharmaceutical
company make money off being
preventative
there's no money in that so as the
consumer of these
products medical services and dental
services we should all be concerned with
preventative
preventative care so yes you're brought
brushing your flossing
uh having a dentist that you trust
look at you and tell you hey this is
going great or this is going bad
uh getting second opinions is always
good i think if you don't
know if you're hearing something that
sounds fishy man dentists are easy to
get into
a lot of them have like you know we run
uh dennis the dental profession in
general is just a little more
of a true capitalism than the health
care industry and so you can go to
another dentist
for example my office if you don't have
any dental insurance
i charge 19 as a promotion to come in
and get a full set of x-rays
and get a full exam 19 bucks gets you
30 to 45 minutes of my time to tell you
what's going on it's not very costly
and so it's super easy and very
accessible
to get another person's opinion on what
you just got told by about your teeth
yeah so you know you sent me a couple
notes on just
sort of what you wanted to talk about so
before we get to
the giveaway specifically you just sort
of mentioned that that dentistry
is a is a capitalist business believe it
or not
with everything going on with health
care and all that can you just talk
about some of the
some of the str the stresses and the
ways that you've been able to succeed
uh having uh having a practice
great question absolutely the biggest
factor in the success of any dentist i
think is our
is our autonomy we own everything that's
in our practice for example when i see
this girl at wendy's
and i want to have compassion on her and
just help her out
i don't have to worry about well who
buys all the materials
for my office who owns all the equipment
who i mean down to the q-tips and the
gauze and the cotton rolls i
buy everything there which gives me 100
percent freedom and autonomy
to give it away or use it at my
discretion how i
choose to do it um i don't think
a medical doctor let's say a heart
surgeon who wants to do free heart
surgery
i think they have a lot more hoops to
jump through than a dentist does in
giving away free mouth makeovers
there's a lot more gatekeepers in
medicine than there are in dentistry
it allows me to really control my own my
own destiny as far as
my success i control prices you know
whatever you know i get a
and i i know within a mile or two radius
what the going rate is for a crown or a
root canal or a dental implant or a
cleaning
i can find all this stuff out and i can
put my prices competitive and i can
actually use the
the positive tenants of capitalism to
make my business successful and if i
fail to do so well then i fail
so you know the biggest difference maker
is our ability to be autonomous
we don't have anyone telling us we don't
have private insurance companies who
boss us around we don't have hospitals
that we work for we don't have large
group practices
there are some of that in dentistry but
for the most part dentists have
maintained their autonomy
throughout the history of dentistry
we're talking teeth and we're getting a
lesson in economics it's a beautiful
thing all right so i'm going to tell the
people how
they can win this smile makeover but why
don't you tell everybody exactly what
you are offering and again this is all
coming out of your pocket you're happy
to do it you're going to fly them out if
if need be so what exactly are you
offering
everything we're offering everything
whatever someone needs
we're going to take care of we got a
team that's going to take care of every
single aspect we're going to take care
of accommodations don't care where you
live as long as you live within the
united states
we'll fly to our location uh there's
some work that once we choose a winner
we gotta figure out what's needed to
kind of coordinate logistics how many
trips it could be two it could be three
but whatever it is we'll take care of
this person we want someone who we want
someone in need
we want to find someone who needs this
whose life is going to be changed by
having this
there are so many people you know
dentistry is such a silent
abuser you know you just don't
so many of these giveaways we've done
they've been nominated by someone who
who loves them like a sister or a or
a parent or a child
and they were blown away by you know my
mom has been suffering for this for
seven years
and i just found out last week that she
has this problem
so even the people closest to you
usually don't know when you're suffering
from a dental problem
and that's that's the that's one of the
biggest issues and so you
you tank into you know depression and
self-consciousness you know and uh you
just feel terrible about yourself
and no one around you knows why because
you're not telling anybody and when the
price tag to fix it is 50
000 you might as well say 50 million
dollars to most people most people
cannot spend that amount of money
on their mouth so what we're offering is
a turnaround for someone you know the
impact
you know one of the things i love about
my job is is this ability to make this
impact and what i love about the
foundation that we've started the halo
dental network
one of the messages we're trying to
prove is the impact of the individual
over any other organization no
government
no organization can be as effective as
an individual
who uses their skills and talents to
lift another individual
up and then trying to disseminate that
and try to make that idea contagious
is the ultimate goal of the of the uh
the halo dental network to do that
so basically you're gonna take care of
people whether the problem
is actually uh you know sort of behind
the scenes or cosmetic or both
there when when they're when you're done
with them they are going to look good
they are going to be happily
happily smiling and and ready to be out
there that's the idea
listen we're we can take someone from
homelessness to hollywood
uh we can do it in a quick period of
time
so we want someone yes whatever the
needs are
we have the ability to cover as long as
they fall into the category of dentistry
we you know this this this part of your
face this part of i can't help you out
anywhere else
whatever you were born with you're born
but uh but wherever your teeth are
we can take someone from nothing to
something pretty special
in a short period of time and then i
mean the thing is
if your teeth are bad if you're in pain
oh my gosh
it's a whole other thing you can't have
relationships you can't carry a job
uh you can't sometimes sleep at night
this makes for a very
rough human being to be around um one of
the biggest misconceptions is that you
see someone with bad teeth
and it's drugs right they're on they
must be on meth
that is one of the biggest
misconceptions that i want to try to
fight also is that
it's that's there's so many factors that
result
in bad teeth you know visibly bad teeth
but the average lay person just sees bad
teeth
and they just think you must be a meth
head one of my favorite patients was a
waitress
who had um she told me a story of on a
receipt
uh that you know that on the bill she
was given also a card
to a uh you know it's like a
like a rehab facility a drug rehab
facility
because the patron of the restaurant
believed that she needed to be
uh given help and the person thought
they were her but it made her feel
terrible she didn't do drugs
it wasn't the problem but now she lives
her life thinking everyone who sees me
thinks i'm a drug addict and i'm not
so man whatever the situation back to
the point yeah whatever the situation
we got coming at us we can handle we can
we can handle anything that someone can
throw at us
man i wish i knew you about eight years
ago when i laid out the 1200 bucks per
tooth
for these porcelain babies right up
front
yeah yeah yeah that helped you out man
we could have we could have set you up
with some kind of payment plan i'm sure
all right forget about me people here
here's what you got to do
join reubenreport.com you can create a
an account for
absolutely free will not cause cost you
a dime
just create an account at
reubenreport.com then we are going to
pin
this interview right up top
and you comment below you can you can do
the sales job for yourself or if you
want to nominate a friend or a family
member who needs some help
comment right below we'll be taking
submissions until
october 2nd and then we'll be announcing
the winner shortly after that and we'll
post some pictures and and maybe we'll
do some video on some
some fun other stuff for instagram and
the rest of it so again create an
account at rubenreport.com
this video my chat with brady smith is
going to be pinned right up top
comment below either for yourself or for
somebody else
and we will pick a winner we're going to
do that till october 2nd you have a
chance
and again i'm not getting anything for
this dr brady is doing this
on his own volition happy to happy to
help you guys we just thought it would
be a fun thing to do
and uh and hopefully help somebody out
dr brady anything else before i let you
go
uh i'm so grateful for you being willing
to
to have this conversation with me and
and and help us do this this is uh you
know one of the things we want to do is
convince dentists
to do a free case a year that's kind of
the main mission of the halo dental
network is
not just me doing it obviously our
impact can be
exponentially increased by having a
thousand
me's around there doing this and what i
find is that dentists do want to do this
they just need a a structure
uh to help them push this and and
and that they know you know dennis out
there they know that
charitable service makes a big
difference in just their day-to-day
uh you know practice so i'm super
grateful
for the opportunity thank you so much i
appreciate it i'm so excited to get
going on this i can't wait to
find out more about who we're choosing
no i'm
listen i'm grateful i'm thrilled to be
doing this with you and again guys go to
reubenreport.com
pin post submit yourself submit a friend
a family member whatever it is and dr
brady
is going to make you go from homeless to
hollywood all right
stay tuned for more thanks doc thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our lifestyle playlist and if
you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell